at least two leading opposition figures
in Venezuela are believed to be in
government custody video appears to show
security officials detaining the men
overnight during raids at their homes
both announced Sunday's election and
called for new protests the vote could
grant president Nicolas Maduro nearly
unchecked power Manuel Bojorquez is in
Caracas with the escalating political
crisis in Venezuela and well good
morning good morning little else is
known right now about the whereabouts of
Leopoldo Lopez and Antonio Ledezma both
men had been previously jailed for
speaking out against the Maduro regime
their arrests do confirm the fears of
the opposition here and many in the
international community who believed
that President Nicolas Maduro would use
this weekend's vote to rewrite the
Constitution as a pretext to jail
suppress and otherwise
silence the opposition this is certain
to only inflame tensions in the streets
where clashes have happened almost daily
between anti-government protesters and
the national police more than 100 people
have been killed since April yesterday
we spoke with Freddy Guevara who is
another outspoken critic and a member of
Venezuela's Congress who is also on Madu
toes list president Maduro said he would
have your jail cell ready to go after
the vote are you concerned well of
course no one wants to be in jail but
I'm more concerned of the future of my
country and more concerned about the
results of this struggle
we checked with Guevara this morning he
has not been detained nah Maduro is also
once again thumbing his nose in
particular at the Trump administration
which slapped sanctions on him yesterday
he said those would do nothing to stop
him Charlie Manuel bark is in Venezuela
thank you